let's jump to this next story and just
get silly from Rolling Stone
from the Trump supporter who called
slavery a choice Kanye West wears white
lives matter t-shirt Candace Owens
matched racist shirts with the rapper
how's that racist racist huh what they
the livestream event saw the music
wearing the shirt as he laid back and
recorded children seemingly from his
donda Academy along with his daughter
North walking around in a circle and all
black as they sang you make forever oh
and conservative Candace Owens even
posed for a photo with West wearing a
matching shirt with a slogan white
supremacists such as the KKK and the
Aryan resistance Society have overtaken
the black lives matter phrase by black
people protesting plate Battalion
reframed it made a defamation league has
categorized the phrase as a hate slogan
well what do you do now when there's two
black people wearing it is it still a
white supremacist thing I don't I don't
I don't know if I who gets to say I
think it's a joke at that point Anderson
doesn't mean it can't be racist
Henderson Anderson Cooper gets to say
the corporate media will of course say
whatever they want to say uh but but
this is you know a slogan that a lot of
law enforcement including the Federal
Bureau of Investigations investigated a
lot of people for for saying uh people
were interrogated for for saying this
slogan in colleges and the ADL also goes
after this particular uh saying as well
so again it all depends on who controls
the narrative who controls the
conversation and yeah I mean I think
they'll label it whatever they want to
label it I think the best troll was when
4chan I think it was 4chan came up with
that sign it said it's okay to be white
yeah and it was the most generic it was
a blank piece of paper with very basic
writings that it's okay to be white like
not even a good not even it was better
or is it good or just it's okay and they
called it white supremacy like if you
literally just said it was okay to be
white they called you a white Supreme
assist but that was the point of the
troll to expose that there was no degree
that they would allow you to be a white
person and live in peace yeah that was
the correct slogan I got it I got the
slogan mixed up I thought it was the
slogan that Kanye was saying but it is
actually the slogan that you mentioned
that in Ohio University had the FBI
involved in an investigation because
someone put up a sign saying it's okay
to be white uh so you know the feds are
keeping a close eye on this and the
corporate media is of course weaponizing
this term to mean whatever they want it
to mean and of course changing the the
real definitions of it I was getting
when I was admitting Minds in like 2016
2017 after Trump got elected there all
of a sudden became a lot of racism
online right after Trump I think he said
some racist stuff in his campaign and
people felt like that was the floodgates
had been opened and they were allowed to
be racist now and what did he say what
did he say yeah
um
he talked about Mexicans like they were
like their own unoffice
he did say that he was calling for a uh
oh yeah Muslim a travel ban which was
that's a religion yeah but it's so it's
a similar like xenophobia kind of thing
appeared and uh I used to get a lot of
white Purity stuff like it's okay to be
white white Purity then it'd be like an
old like Galax white kind of Nazi we
were just talking about how it's okay to
be white as a kind of a banal statement
yeah I would get overloaded with it in
my administrative ship I'd get these
just it's okay to be white it's okay to
be white white priv like white is
beautiful and it's like yeah it's it's
racist whether or not it's hateful I
don't know but it's definitely like you
could tell it wasn't just people
expressing their love for being white it
was like they were trying to dig in on
it so I get why they're treating it like
that I don't agree that it's a hate I
hate tactic but I see why no the point
of it's okay to be white as a saying was
to prove that even saying something as
mediocre as that would result in your
exact reaction right now calling it
racist yeah well it is
not racist because they're picking a
race and they're making a generalization
it's okay it's okay to be white I am
saying like I love black women that's a
racist statement that's not just a race
it's proving the point of the meme right
now your reaction they didn't say
anything good or bad it's okay there's
Big R racism which is like systemic
hateful like they're my race is better
than that race then there's little our
racism where you're just talking about
race it's just a racist conversation
like it's okay to have a racist
conversation as long as you're not like
systemically racist you know what I'm
saying changing the definition of word
there's two different ways to be racist
and one is like the hateful one that
everyone's trying to avoid then the
other one is like you pick out a race
and you make all these generalizations
about it but that's not what it's okay
to be white was that was what they were
just generalizing like it's okay to be
this race and it's like I get it it is
but they weren't just
you know it wasn't it wasn't improving
the point you're proving the name right
what's what's the point what if it was
another race it would have been exactly
the same same as right if it's okay to
be Indian it's okay to be Chinese like
it's you know but it is okay to be
Indian it is okay it's also generally a
racist statement but it is okay oh is it
racist because you're talking about race
and you're making a generalization about
it
I thought thought for you thought for
you you're from Chicago right
probably the biggest holiday in Chicago
they turn the river green that's right
there's a day called St Patrick's Day
and and that day there are shirts that
say Kiss Me I'm Irish or everyone's
Irish today is that racist well it's
natural to say so
it's Nationalist and like that that's
also weird distinction like African
doesn't mean black you know Irish
doesn't mean white so like race and
nationality are kind of different is
Elon Musk an African-American
technically yeah literally yeah I don't
know what else what is what are you
supposed to say to it like if the
argument is that race is social
construct because the color of your skin
varies among cultures then Elon Musk
being from Africa would be an
African-American by that argument and
Luke apparently according to a group
called The Coalition of communities of
color Luke with blue eyes and blonde
hair is a person of color I am sorry by
definition peach pink yellowish color
so am I okay to be a person of color Ian
you certainly are Luke oh that was
racist that's racist but I was
I didn't know there's had anything to do
with the race
no no for real there's an organization
that said Slavic people are people of
color so Luke being from Poland is it's
a big I think that's what Hitler thought
I mean did he not did he not think they
were like inferior people yeah yeah yeah
the Polish like chapters about this yeah
this is so weird the Germans didn't like
the Polish nope not at all yeah either
of the Russian Superior for that one
nope yeah I want to like detach people
from being I don't want people to feel
afraid to talk about race like it's
important that we talk about race and
like genetic differences it's because
there are genetic differences in humans
historically because our ancestors lived
in different areas with different
climates their bodies evolved
differently and it's interesting that is
still racial if not small are racist
conversations to be like these this
genetic type of person tends to be
taller this genetic type of person tends
to be able to do math faster because of
some you know you can see if it maybe
it's a genetic issue as well as like a a
cultural thing that's fine as long as
you don't start saying this one's better
than that one which is the actual
definition of racism here at Miriam
Webster uh that
race leads is the fundamental
determinant of a human trait and
capacity that racial differences produce
an inherent superiority of a particular
race that is the Miriam Webster number
one definition on Google searches what
are the other generations of a racism
right but I think Polish people cook
cabbage better than Americans so is that
racist no I think that's just like
cultures doing things better there's
some cultures that do things
growing and utilizing cabbage yo skin
color comes the skin color is just a
function of where your ancestors came
from and how close they were to the
equator because melanin is just
something that your body naturally
produces based on how much sunlight you
get and it is a protective it's less
about like you want to hear some biology
than anything it's more about the The
Wonder of the design of your body to
protect you from a lot of UV light make
sure that you can like up that you're
not gonna be harmed by I write the
amount of UV light that your ancestors
were from all right this crazy thing
about black frogs in uh Ukraine and uh
it's because of Chernobyl so what
happened is frog the frogs were green
most of them but there were some that
had darker skin
when the radiation leak came out the
green skin frogs all started dying the
melanin in the black frogs because
they're like dark brown dark black was a
was dissipating the radioactive energy
and so they were more likely to survive
wow so 20 some odd years on they
reproduced in the whole area around
Chernobyl is populated by black frogs
wow yeah that's crazy this is melanin
man this is why even like the term white
doesn't quite make any sense what do you
mean by white like what like what color
white right like what color what what do
you mean color if you if your white
person moves down to Mexico City as you
said and uh a hipster who is like
translucent from you know like the Upper
East Side goes to Mexico City they will
develop a tan over time their skin will
become darker they will have a different
in 10 years man living in Mexico City
they will have a different complexion
entirely they won't even look like the
same person and that's just the Wonder
of the body and your body protecting
itself and making sure you don't get
skin cancer and you'll get sunburned all
day I wonder if that that melanin study
and radioactivity would mean that white
people are less less uh likely to
survive radioactive fallout interesting
yeah that's bringing it full circle that
was impressive we had a video game where
you could be like all right we need to
deal with certain things what race of
person am I going to send in to deal
with that because they can handle that
situation better I need people to be I
need people to be like uh camouflage in
the ice all right I'm gonna pick a white
person I need people to be camouflaged
at night or I'll pick a black person and
of course no one's white or black but
their Skin's more likely to blend in
with the surroundings or you could love
it or or they could use face paint and I
tell you humans are phenomenal I don't
care what skin color you got for where
you're from you have the ability to
change the world man and learn stuff
that no one else has learned way to go
yes and that's why that's why the
definition of racism is saying that one
race is better than the other not saying
that it's okay to be a race well what
about just making generalizations
inherently racist
it's okay to be Indian too in Chinese
but I think it I guess it's we're using
different definitions of the word race
which obviously there are racism rather
because if you just make a
generalization about a race this is
something I learned growing up I'd be
like oh people be like I love black
black women are so beautiful and I'd be
like well that's racist you know you're
making a generalization about black
people black women and they're like I I
guess technically and then we laugh
because it's like yeah I see what you're
saying but saying it's okay to be a race
isn't racist because you're not
generalizing on anybody you're just
saying like yeah it's okay it's like
it's actually the opposite of racism
it's saying like it's it's it's okay
it's preference no it's it's not even
that it's just like it would be racist
to be like it's not okay to be white
that would be racist but being like no
it's it's like we are tolerant and
accepting of other races that's not
racist that's the opposite of it
I think once you start talking about
race like that you're you're basically
creating a racist conversation so maybe
not Big R maybe not like hatefully but
so what if someone said it's not okay to
be white is that racist yeah I think so
there's no there's no circumstance like
if you start bringing white and black
and skin color and stuff into
conversations you're being a ray you're
you're you're now a racist Converse it's
a racist conversation no but it's not
the same definition of the hateful like
you know xenophobia kind of crap
do we used to talk be so obsessed with
Race So speaking of Chicago I grew up
with the Michael Jordan poster on my
wall I think I was aware that he was a
different skin color than me but it
didn't really matter I idealized the guy
I think it was really great I had his
jersey like I I think I was great his
his poster along with Shaquille O'Neal's
poster hung on my wall and never once
did I think like that's cool because
because of their school well they say
that's white privilege the fact that you
didn't have to think about it proves
that you had privilege
but I was saying these guys are like
pretty great for us these people don't
seem to have a good logic behind what
their ideology is I definitely noticed
it when I was like it felt like in the
90s there was like a different
conversation about I think maybe no one
was having a conversation about race you
can check the term racism in the New
York Times and how they use it and it's
like skyrocketed since around when
Occupy Wall Street yep since I lost you
we were pretty racist growing up and
they called it Caucasian Falls where I'm
from it was like 99 white kids and like
uh it was really gross and I didn't know
any better like we just grew up like if
the stuff we said when I was 12 was on
the internet I'd still be humiliated
like it would still be like haunting me
to this day and I had to learn like yo I
would make jokes about gay people it was
just like effeminate jokes and stuff and
then in college I went to theater school
and they're like you know that's really
offensive Ian and so I stopped and I was
like you know but that was raised in a
really racist environment when I went to
South America I noticed that I looked
different than people and that was what
Tim's saying about white privilege is
the privilege of looking like the
majority of the people around you like
skin tone because when their skin was
dark they look at me and they'd be like
Thor you know they would say they would
look at me and like you look like Thor
from the movie oh I'm gonna make it
share with you on it that says Thor yeah
Chris Hemsworth you have gray hair
thanks sir
when uh when I traveled around most
places I never experienced that because
everywhere I go no one can tell what I
am so I remember this one story uh that
I've told before when I was in Egypt and
I'm in the I'm in the back of this with
this van with a bunch of Egyptians and
the vice producer I'm with is this white
dude with brown hair and blue eyes and
he looks over to me and he's like okay
Tim
we're gonna play it cool we're gonna
listen to what our our fixers tell us to
do because once we get out there ain't
no one gonna believe we're not a couple
of white guys and every single Egyptian
ghost no Tim looks Egyptian and I was
like oh really they're like yeah yeah
especially with the hat because people
wear hats like that so they were like no
no you should come and I went to Nasser
city where the Muslim Brotherhood was
no problem in fact one guy even came up
one guy even came up to me started
yelling something in Arabic and I just
like smiled and then the guy I was with
started answering him in Arabic and then
as we walked away started laughing and
he was like dude he thought you were
like like a monk or a mom or something
because you're wearing the Hat he was
asking where the mosque was and I was
like really the same hat not the same
hat but similar style beanie and uh you
know I've been to South America
typically when I go to a lot of places
people can't tell you know so I just
kind of like drift about what what is
your what is your I mean German Irish
Korean Japanese especially if everyone
on Earth had a baby it would look like
you but your skin would be a little
darker if your skin gets yeah if your
skin got a little darker that's like the
future of humanity when everybody starts
except here's the thing most woke
liberals don't think I'm white they
think I'm not white until until it
becomes political politically expedient
but it's like the weirdest thing because
if it's white people who think I'm not
white I don't worry about anything
because they're not racist to me and
then when I go to other countries and
they just think I fit in with their
country then I don't got to worry about
it because even if they are racist they
think I'm same as them you know it's
weird how that works did you ever feel
uh like people tell me stories about
Egypt and they say like it's
uncomfortable there and that it's not
like that nice of a place is it true I
don't know I had a blast yeah yeah I
mean it was it was a revolution
happening so but I went to the mall
walked around totally normal it was cool
um inexpensive yeah like the the guy I
was with told me to shut up because we
went to a fast food restaurant when I
found out I was like a dollar for a meal
I was like whoa and there's like shhh
he's like this is a lot of money to
these people he's like you're American
you're something like a like an a-hole
and I was like oh whoa you're right man
that was bad I shouldn't do that but I
was like really excited because I could
get food and I was kind of broke and I
like this is amazing
and then you know to them they were like
Rich American shows up
not people aren't gonna be too happy
with that but I think the guy I was with
got like attacked in an alley because he
did look like a white American dude he
got surrounded and then some other dude
came up and started getting the guys to
back away and like told him not to do it
and they were like I guess once they
what the the there's a bunch of Egyptian
guys got in the face of the vice
producer and like cornered him and then
some other guy came up and was basically
saying in Arabic or something like
you're gonna attack an American
journalist you're gonna make us all look
bad it's going to hurt us you got to
stop and then got him and then he put
his hand up and then looked at the
producers like go now
it's crazy stuff man thanks for checking
out this segment from the timcast IRL
podcast but if you want to check out the
full show live tune in Monday through
Friday at 8pm and if you want more
special access content head over to
timcast.com and become a member your
membership helps sustain this company
keep our journalists employed makes this
show happen and you will get access to
exclusive members only segments of the
timcast IRL podcast and there's a
massive library to check out so again go
to timcast.com or tune in Monday through
Friday at 8pm and we'll see you all
there